question is who should it be the leading
contender right now
amy coney barrett
three words that strike fear under the
heart of the liberals who is amy barrett
she's an appeals court judge
she's a mother of seven five biological
children two adopted children from haiti
she's a law professor obviously
qualified we don't know much about
her judicial philosophy actually we know
she clerked for scalia
but you know she's young she's been on
the bench not too long
still the left hates her guts why two
big reasons first one they hate her
primarily because
she's catholic here is senator democrat
dianne feinstein
lambasting her because the catholic
dogma lives loudly within her
when you read your speeches
the conclusion one draws
is that the dogma lives
loudly within you and
that's of concern when you come to big
issues
that large numbers of people have fought
for
for years in this country it's a big
concern
because catholics aren't allowed on the
supreme court because
our constitution establishes a religious
test for president
and you need to belong to the religion
of secular liberalism you can't possibly
be a christian
that would be un-american that's the
argument she's making
luckily dianne feinstein is far too
ignorant to know that that's the
argument that she's making but it's a
deeply anti-american argument the things
she is saying
right there violate the constitution
even
asking those questions is a violation of
the constitution
dick durbin another leading democrat a
little bit quicker on his feet than
dianne feinstein
falls into precisely the same trap you
use a term in that article or
you both used a term that article i'd
never seen before you refer to orthodox
catholics
what's an orthodox catholic um
as i recall that term we said something
like for lack of a better term we're
using the term orthodox catholic and
there was a long
footnote saying you know that that was
an imperfect term
it could you know refer to orthodox
judaism you know greek orthodox
and so we kind of cast about but what
that term was designed to capture
because we were talking about
conscientious objection was a judge
who um accepted the church's teaching
that the death penalty would be
impermissible in that case
do you consider yourself an orthodox
catholic i am a catholic
senator durbin i i don't well orthodox
catholic we kind of
as i said in that article we just kind
of use that as a proxy
it is not to my knowledge you know a
term currently in use but if you're
asking whether i take my faith seriously
and i'm a
faithful catholic i am although i would
stress
that my personal church affiliation or
my religious belief would not bear on
the discharge of my duties as a judge
she gave a very long judicial
sort of judicious answer here but
a simpler answer is what do you mean
you've never heard of
orthodox catholic dick durbin
is not a stupid man he says i've never
heard that orthodox catholic
well let me spell it out for you senator
durbin orthodox
meaning you actually believe the things
that you say that you believe catholic
meaning you're a catholic
you're you're part of the catholic
church you could be a heterodox catholic
meaning you consider yourself a catholic
but you don't believe the things
that the catholic church believes you
could be a heretic a heretical catholic
you could openly preach things against
what the catholic church teaches
even though you consider yourself a
catholic or you can be an orthodox
catholic
and actually believe the things the
catholic church teaches and that's the
issue here
because when democrats use the term
catholic
they say i'm a devout catholic my
catholic faith is important to me
what they really mean is i
have christmas dinner i maybe go to mass
sometimes if i want to
that's what they mean joe biden's a
devout catholic he thinks that
taxpayers should should pay to kill
babies in the womb up until the moment
of birth
but he's a which which catholics are not
permitted to believe
but you know he's a devout catholic some
democrats say yeah
i support socialism but i'm a devout
catholic you're not allowed to be a
socialist
if you're a catholic so what they mean
by devout catholic is
they think that religion is this kind of
little ornament and it's this sweet
little thing that maybe you do in the
privacy of your own home
because you're afraid of the dark and
it's a little superstition like knocking
on wood
or or any other superstition but you
don't take it seriously you don't think
it means anything
you certainly don't believe all that
crazy
stuff that those churches say and the
democrats are shocked to find
a woman who's intelligent who is
articulate
who is accomplished who actually thinks
it's true
and now there are a lot of catholics and
and and christians and people who think
this way
but the democrats don't meet them
they're always shocked
you know you couldn't possibly believe
that stuff so that's the first reason
they hate her second reason they hate
her
is because she disproves all their
stupid theories about how women are
supposed to be
on paper she is everything
a woman should be or could be the left
always says
women can have it all right and usually
what that means is
that women should go and delay getting
married and delay having children and
just work for the widget factory
and you know they should go cut their
hair and they should go
only vote for democrats and they should
have lots of abortions
and they should uh i don't know what are
all the things i'm trying to
mix the high and the low you know you
get like stupid like
really like ugly haircuts like do you
remember that thing that the democrats
were doing years ago the feminist women
were
it's like it was very unpleasant and
the very important things like they
should
engage in abortion or they should form
families in a certain way this or that
or this or that
that's what the democrats say you can
you can have it all
that's the promise that you can have a
career
have a family have kids
do all these things you want usually it
doesn't work out that way
so you have to fall into one one camper
the other but for amy barrett it did
work out that way
she had five biological kids she then
adopted two children from haiti they'll
find some way to call her a racist i'm
sure
she found a way to have this incredibly
successful legal career
and yet they still hate her how do they
hate her
she did what most of them never could do
she had it all well
it's because she doesn't think the way
that they do
new york times runs a piece two
conservatives barrett has perfect
combination of attributes for the
supreme court
maybe that's true for conservatives but
actually it's more true for liberals
the headline should read to liberals
barrett has the perfect combination of
attributes for the supreme court
she's a woman and they think that a
woman needs to replace ruth ginsburg
she's has it all she has had this great
career but she hasn't had to sacrifice
in her personal life
or not at least that we can see she
checks all of these kind of boxes right
i don't care that amy barrett's a woman
i don't think a woman needs to replace
rbg on the supreme court i don't think a
woman needs to
have it all you know needs to have this
very intense career and have a total
family life i don't
i don't think you have to do that but
they do
and she did it but she doesn't think the
way that they think
so now all of a sudden
they hate her they're going to try to
kick her out we absolutely should push
her through
if for no other reason than to trigger
the libs it'll be very very funny
uh also the reason we need to push her
through i think we should all get on
board
if it's her it might be there are a
couple other people who are being talked
about she's the leading contender right
now
but the reason we need to push through
this nominee if the nominee is in any
way acceptable to conservatives
is because we're in a bare-knuckle
moment of politics right now we're not
in a nice deliberative moment of
politics where
all these judicial nominees get
unanimously confirmed
that's gone and the democrats ruined
that and so we've got to play
we've got to participate in the politics
that we actually have
this is bare knuckle stuff i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts